you saw him yesterday in pennsylvania
where they you know they managed to let
him out of the basement basically so
they could cut an ad
to make it look like he's actually out
there you know it's all from the same
shot but you know joe biden was out of
his basement miraculously for a few
minutes but
he forgets where he is he forgets his
wife from his sister
he forgets the office he's running for
he's he's looking at notes you see him i
mean he literally read the subtext
of the teleprompter stuff it looks like
he's trying to give an organic interview
but he's reading
the bullet points on a teleprompter
because he can't remember them and now
you compare that with
okay two brain aneurysms is probably an
issue nothing to see here folks
i mean the cause and effect is so
flagrant and it
it would be sad dave if it wasn't so
scary for our country
so i read about half the book this
morning and you just laid out a lot of
the arguments that you made and when i
was
when i was looking at it i was thinking
you know the the alternate title
basically for this book
could have been double standards right
because that's really what you're
that's really what you're saying in this
book that if my family did these things
this is how the media would have
portrayed it if my dad had made these
decisions
this is what would happen and if i had
gotten the the benefits that say hunter
biden had gotten
this is how the media would have dealt
it i i've said a lot of people
as as i've gotten more comfortable let's
say with your dad a lot of people will
say to me
well i don't get it dave how could you
how could you support trump how is he
how come you don't think he's the devil
all of that kind of stuff
and what i always say is well he
understood
the media more than anything else that
it wasn't just
it wasn't just republicans versus
democrats it was republicans versus
democrats
plus the media that that to me seems to
be a huge thrust of what this book is is
it
does it all boil down to the double
standards thing for you
yeah i mean yes and even and and more
right i mean because it's not just
a double standard it's just flagrant
mistakes i mean
if you just look at what's going on
today you know there was another fake
report you know donald trump suffered
uh many strokes you know now and he had
to be treated at walter reed now the
doctors at walter reed said this is
nonsense it's
untrue but the media won't even talk
about joe biden who's literally had
two brain surgeries for literally
brain aneurysms he had explosions in his
brain
now if you ask a doctor about that what
are the chances that you could be a
hundred percent normal after one
you know brain surgery that you know
after an aneurysm they'd say very little
how about two almost impossible to be
normal now
you take that with joe biden's daily
daily you saw him yesterday in
pennsylvania
where they you know they managed to let
him out of the basement basically so
they could cut an ad
to make it look like he's actually out
there you know it's all from the same
shot but you know joe biden was out of
his basement miraculously for a few
minutes but
he forgets where he is he forgets his
wife from his sister
he forgets the office he's running for
he's he's looking at notes you see him i
mean he literally read the subtext
of the teleprompter stuff it looks like
he's trying to give an organic interview
but he's reading
the bullet points on a teleprompter
because he can't remember them and now
you compare that with
okay two brain aneurysms is probably an
issue nothing to see here folks
i mean the cause and effect is so
flagrant and it
it would be sad dave if it wasn't so
scary for our country
you know joe biden is basically he's
camouflaged
for the far left they can try to the
media will spend billions trying to sell
him to middle america it's moderate joe
moderate joe but you know you're not a
moderate with kamala as your vp
you're not a moderate with beto hell
yeah i'll take your ar-15 o'rourke as
your guns are you're sure it's like not
a moderate with
the bernie sanders joint unity platform
which is like a com
combination of like the new age
communist manifesto with the green new
deal blended into one
and again the media won't talk about
that so when you talk about
you know double standard it's not even
that because the playing field is so
uneven with a mainstream media that's
what 96
negative against donald trump i mean
that's a lot of ground to overcome they
won't talk about the good things you saw
well you may have been off the grid when
this happened but they got a peace deal
done in the middle east
i was just gonna bring it up yeah this
is the holy grail of geopolitical
politics hasn't been done in a quarter
of a century
they spent more time last week
fact-checking my three-year-old nephew
if in fact he did build a lego white
house for my father now there's a
picture of it
but they spend more time talking about
that because ivanka mentioned it in her
speech
attacking a three-year-old now i mean
you know nick sandman at 16 they
destroyed him i figured
okay they wouldn't go much lower than
that but now they're going to a
three-year-old
to attack him but the average american
has no idea we signed a peace deal in
the middle east
and you know that's the insanity we're
up against so that's why this book it's
not just for
you know people on the right it's for
people in the middle who are undecided
because if you're undecided and you're
sort of going 50 50 either way
imagine you actually knew about joe
biden and his policies imagine you
actually heard about the trump
administration's successes
neither of which you've been made aware
of that's what this book is it's
designed to inform and again it's more
for the people in the middle that aren't
sure than it is anything else because
someone had to step up and do it
so in the in the chapter about the biden
health stuff where you talk about the
brain aneurysms and everything else and
you refer to
obama's doctor and a bunch of other
medical professionals in it
and you actually go out of your way to
make a point that you're not trying to
mock the guy and you have sympathy for
this kind of stuff like
you're not being a dick about it you're
really not um
one thing that you sort of hint at is
basically and you sort of implied this
already
that he's just kind of a puppet for
something
what what do you really think that thing
is like
is it is it the party apparatus like who
really is in charge
of the dnc at this point well i think
it's the radical left i mean you saw
that you saw that
if you watched the dnc i don't know if
you came out of hiding yet from that one
uh
if you didn't catch it i'm catching up
now it'll save you a lot of grief
because if you watch that you know
you'd think that america was the most
oppressive regime ever created in the
world and that it's a terrible place and
you know again i watched for five days
not one person mentioned the looting
the writing the violence going not one
at the dnc they had a week
instead they painted this picture of you
know america's a terrible place if you
like anything about it you're a terrible
human being
and you know that's the thing i wasn't
trying to make light of dementia or
alzheimer's i mean we all know people
affected by it
the difference is those people can have
a great life they can be great parents
and grandparents and have
we're not going to give them the nuclear
football we're going to we're going to
just
pretend that didn't happen and say
congratulations here's the largest
economy in the world
here's the nuclear football i mean if
joe biden needs notes to talk to
a reporter that's literally trying to
lob him softballs
how is he going to compete against china
and russia and iran
like he can't remember where he is i
mean so you know it's
it's either insane or it's a cloak and
dagger type of thing where they you know
they
cover your eyes they pretend it's
moderate joe from scranton of which he's
not i mean he's not blue collar joe
he got his first elected official office
in dc when he was in his 20s like he's
never had a blue collar job but
you know he's curated this sort of lie
to market himself as this way so the
radical left who's actually making all
the decisions again
his platform on his website is bernie
sanders
right you know his vp is kamala harris
who's literally left of bernie sanders
in terms of voting record in the senate
like do you think joe biden's going to
be able to stand up to them
if they're pushing for certain things no
but the media can use him as camo
you know to sell to middle america no no
it's not going to be that radical it's
not going to be that bad but all you
have to do is look at this platform i
mean
four trillion dollar tax hike to middle
class america to give
free health care to illegals free
education to illegals
uh free lawyers for the other ones that
will start flooding our country like
who's that gonna hurt
probably not me it's gonna hurt our
lowest income earners
right who's that going to hurt how about
you in a public school that you have the
privilege
of having to pay for yet again right you
don't get free health care you don't get
free education for your kids certainly
not college or anything
but you have the privilege of paying for
illegals to get those benefits
because it creates democrat voters i
mean think about how insane that is it's
not like our systems
have all this excess capacity that they
can handle it i mean they're already
overworked
our medical system is already
overstressed our education system
honestly our public education system is
a disaster it's 28th in the world
spending more money per child than any
country in the world it's still 28th
i mean there are literally third world
countries that are beating us in
education
and the teachers union is really sure
they don't want to go back to do
in-person learning
but they also don't want to do online
learning also part of their platform
since you've been gone is they want to
support blm
and defund the police what does that
have to do with educating our children
these are the radicals that we're going
to be in charge and if you just look at
joe biden you see the way he has to be
carried off the stage after he gives a
speech
or you know speech i say speech loosely
because
you know the hardest job in america is
being his sign language interpreter
because everyone no one knows what that
is going on
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell